bonsoir bonsoir à tous je suis ravie
d'être là je vais tricher je suis sûr
que les étudiants ils aimeraient bien
être à ma place
comme voilà comme présenté je suis chef
de cuisine et je me passionne pour tout
ce qui touche à l'alimentation depuis
mon plus jeune âge d'ailleurs j'ai des
très très vieux souvenirs que j'aimerais
vous partager sur la nourriture je me
souviens la fois où j'ai chassé des
escargots dans mon jardin parce que je
trouve ça croustillant je vous conseille
pas ou la fois où j'ai provoqué la
panique dans ma famille et parce que on
me cherchait partout j'étais dans un
jardin où on faisait de la cueillette et
je me suis endormie en dessous d'un
magnifique pied d'haricots verts c'était
fabuleux bref ma passion est arrivée
très très tôt et
c'était finalement quelque chose d'assez
naturel pour moi j'ai d'ailleurs
longuement hésité entre l'agriculture et
la cuisine car pour moi c'était presque
la même chose mais bon en tant que
banlieue du 93 c'était quand même un pas
d'aller de la ville à la gadoue et les
bottes donc j'ai choisi la cuisine
surtout que je suis extrêmement
gourmande
j'ai eu un parcours assez éclectique que
j'aimerais vous vous
transmettre car au début pour me
dégoûter mes parents m'ont envoyé en
stage alors je vous explique un petit
peu le concept du stage avec mes parents
ils m'ont envoyé dans les commerces des
quartiers qu'ils connaissaient les
bouchers les maraîchers les boulangers
les bistrots du coin ma mère
m'a carrément fait travailler dans la
cantine dans la cantine scolaire de son
école là où elle l'enseignait je vous
dis pas 14 ans avec mon filet à cheveux
j'étais magnifique
mais malgré tous leurs efforts pour me
dégoûter et me faire changer d'avis et
ben j'ai adoré je suis tombée amoureuse
de ce métier de ce grand grand métier
qui englobe énormément de choses
j'ai donc intégré un bac technologique
qui était quand même un joli compromis
avec mes parents car il y avait le mot
bac
et c'est là que j'ai fait mes premiers
vrais apprentissage avec mes premiers
vrais stages dans de très belles
brasseries parisiennes c'était
incroyable j'ai adoré la brigade le
rythme du service les odeurs les
produits c'était le paradis ça change
d'ici je vous l'assure et puis
j'apprends mon vrai métier être en
cuisine et cuisiner
ça m'a suffi moi mais mes chefs m'ont
poussé à faire des grandes écoles je les
ai écoutées donc j'étais pas prête du
tout mais j'ai quand même intégré une
grande école l'Institut Paul Bocuse à
Lyon
j'ai littéralement halluciné moi qui
viens banlieue je suis arrivé au portes
ouvertes c'était un château enfin
c'était j'ai failli ne pas y ne pas y
aller tellement j'avais peur on a fait
on avait fait 450 km avec mes parents
et c'était le stress clairement je me
sentais pas à ma place j'avais peur donc
j'ai pas pris la petite carte de uno
mais j'ai failli j'ai voulu changer mon
esprit en me disant c'est fait pour toi
ne t'inquiète pas personne n'y verra
rien tu vas durer tout le monde et tu
vas y arriver
alors là j'ai découvert les chefs
Meilleurs Ouvriers de France les meufs
les cuisines
suréquipées avec des magnifiques
casseroles toutes étincelante
le restaurant d'application
gastronomique s'il vous plaît le centre
de recherche les produits de luxe qu'on
pouvait travailler les vrais vrais vrais
stages dans des établissements
exceptionnels que je n'aurais jamais pu
rêver je vous l'assure j'ai découvert
tout un pan de la cuisine j'ai côtoyé de
près l'univers des chefs qui font
aujourd'hui
voilà le
[Applaudissements]
bref je soupçonnais même pas l'existence
de certaines pratiques en cuisine et
c'était exceptionnel et j'ai d'ailleurs
j'ai découvert l'art de tromper les
cerveaux j'y arrive c'était ma
transition
en vérité l'art de tromper les cerveaux
est partout en cuisine comme on vient de
le voir dans ma petite expérience
personnelle c'est extrêmement large la
cuisine donc j'ai essayé d'être assez
concise la cuisine c'est large donc
c'est compliqué à expliquer
on a besoin de transformer les produits
bruts que nous donne la nature pour nous
nourrir et pour moi transformer un
produit c'est cuisiner donc qu'on le
veuille ou non qu'on cuisine ou pas
quelqu'un ou quelque chose le fait pour
nous un moment ou un autre ça peut être
une maman un époux un ami un
professionnel
un membre d'une brigade un chef dans
tout type de lieux dans un restaurant de
quartier dans une cantine d'entreprise
dans le restaurant du dernier chef à la
mode ou dans un fast-food ou ça peut
être carrément fait par une usine
construit et créée par des chimistes
transformés et assemblée par des
machines et chacun d'eux cuisine et à la
capacité de tromper vos cerveaux car oui
quand on nous parle de tromper les
cerveaux franchement la première chose
que je me suis dit c'est le trompe
l'oeil cette fameuse épreuve de Top Chef
que tout le monde redoute parce que
personne sait faire parce que finalement
pour faire un trompe l'oeil bah c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre d'ingénierie de techniques
ce sont des prodiges des grands chefs
qui créent ce genre de perfectionnement
et de tromperie au niveau de l'oeil du
goût et des sens
c'est des moments inoubliables
d'ailleurs quand on vous trompe votre
cerveau lorsqu'on vous propose un trompe
l'oeil c'est inoubliable ça crée des
souvenirs parce que lorsqu'on croit
manger un œuf au plat en fait c'est une
tarte citron franchement ça m'en bouche
un coin mais ça ça serait comme pensée
uniquement à Gérard Majax ou à David
Copperfield quand on parle de magie à
l'opposé mais qui font tout aussi de la
magie il y a aussi les pickpockets de
Montparnasse
et oui et aussi à toutes les nuances
entre ces deux extrêmes et bien c'est
pareil avec la cuisine la seule
différence c'est que l'on mange deux à
trois fois par jour ou plus je vais donc
essayer de vous dépeindre trois grandes
familles trois grandes familles
techniques qui existent pour tromper les
cerveaux en cuisine et vous verrez que
ces techniques sont parfois utilisées
dans toutes les strates de la cuisine de
l'usine au restaurant étoilé il ne
s'agit donc pas de vous faire fuir
lorsqu'on utilise cette technique de
tromper les cerveaux mais bien de vous
éclairer dans ce domaine car l'unique
différence entre le bon ou le mauvais
usage de cette technique et de savoir si
elle est utilisée avec bienveillance ou
malveillance
la première grande famille je l'ai
intitulé les couleurs les textures et
les formes
une des premières choses qu'on apprend
quand on cuisine c'est qu'on mange avec
les yeux vous le savez on l'a souvent
répété dans le monde culinaire donc ça
doit être beau
plus beau que la nature si possible
et ça peut être très étonnant surprenant
voire spectaculaire c'est encore mieux
en changeant les couleurs les textures
et les formes des aliments il est très
facile de tromper les cerveaux et vous
n’imaginez pas l'étendue des techniques
et surtout des produits que nous avons
nous à disposition pour cela c'est
d'ailleurs la plus grande famille que je
vais vous présenter et aborder aborder
avec vous tranquille c'est courant ça va
aller vite côté bienveillance cela peut
être fait grâce à des produits naturels
de techniques de culinaires comme je
fais en cuisine par exemple extraire la
chlorophylle c'est-à-dire la couleur
verte du nerbe d'une salade pour recréer
le côté vert d'un aliment ou alors je
marine un petit peu mes viandes avec du
jus d'ananas ça attendri les chair je
change un petit peu la texture des
aliments
ou encore je prends toutes sortes de
moules en silicone pour créer des
illusions et
changer la structure même d'un produit
avec ces techniques je peux donc
maîtriser la couleur la texture la forme
et créer autant d'illusions que je
souhaite
alors malheureusement il ne faut pas
oublier le côté malveillant je l'ai
appelé le côté obscur de la force
et dans le domaine des couleurs des
textures il faut être extrêmement
vigilant car il y a du monde
xanthane malodextrine
transglutaminases Nouga 7
pectagel galimat la plus grande marque
française d'agents de texture et de
colorants
on propose plus d'une centaine
évidemment les industries en raffole
mais détrompez-vous j'en ai vu aussi
dans des très grands restaurants
gastronomiques et on appelle ça
l'armoire à pharmacie ces grandes boîtes
blanches avec des couleurs bien rouge et
une grosse tête de mort juste derrière
alors oui ça existe et il y en a
beaucoup
il y en a beaucoup dans les produits
transformés que réchauffent
malheureusement certaines brasseries
comme les poudres qui servent à faire
des sauces et beaucoup
beaucoup
en pâtisserie
et dans ce cas-là vous ne savez pas et
vous ne lisez pas l'étiquette c'est
quand même magnifique de voir des
magnifiques choses dans des boutiques
dans des vitrines mais vous ne savez pas
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur donc la
première astuce c'est déjà de lire
l'étiquette quand il y en a une c'est
quand même extrêmement important c'est
la base mais ça ne suffit pas il faut
aussi aiguiser ses sens ne pas se fier
aux apparences et cela commence par
savoir déjà que ça existe
quand c'est trop beau et que c'est pas
cher méfiance
la deuxième grande famille que
j'aimerais aborder avec vous c'est le
sel et le sucre et oui c'est une famille
à elle seule
à eux seuls puisque il y a le sucre et
le sel il y a une phrase que je dis
souvent c'est vrai si quelqu'un n'aime
pas quelque chose on a qu'à rajouter un
petit peu de sucre un petit peu de sel
et vous allez kiffer
c'est très simple de tromper vos
cerveaux avec du sel et du sucre côté
bienveillance par exemple
j'ajoute souvent un petit peu de sucre
dans mes préparations salées ça donne un
petit goût sucré ça arrondi ça adoucit
ça casse certaines fois de l'acide le
côté acide le côté amer
un petit peu trop présent peut-être dans
certains plats quand on fait des oignons
par exemple j'adore cette petite astuce
on saupoudre un petit peu de sucre
pareil pour les endives ou pour les
choux de Bruxelles c'est magnifique ça
rend tout délicieux et pourtant ça ne se
sent pas le sucre
et donc pareil pour le sel j'en ajoute
un petit peu surtout dans les
préparations sucrées pour donner du
corps aux préparations je vous conseille
la petite fleur de sel dans le brownie
c'est merveilleux
le problème c'est quand on en abuse et
là le côté obscur revient oui toujours
et ici alors là faut vraiment lire les
étiquettes mais ça ne suffit pas ce que
je vous conseille c'est de recréer la
recette à la maison prenez par exemple
le ketchup si vous refaites à la maison
en respectant les proportions du ketchup
que vous achetez ça vous permet de vous
rendre compte quand c'est vous qui
mettez tout ce sucre dans la casserole
et tout ce sel sel le choc est immédiat
c'est immédiat parce que il y en a
terriblement trop
pour nous professionnelle c'est donc
facile de vous surprendre et de tromper
vos cerveaux parce que tout simplement
on en met plus que vous à la maison et
donc pas ses meilleurs
[Rires]
vous êtes trop gentil
c'est tellement dur
[Applaudissements]
la troisième grande famille que
j'aimerais aborder avec vous c'est les
épices et les arômes et oui c'est bien
joli d'avoir des textures des couleurs
du sel du sucre on peut faire déjà
énormément de choses mais avec les
épices et les arômes c'est encore un
autre chant des possibles qui s'offrent
à vous pour tromper les cerveaux pour
commencer avec la bonne armoire à épices
je peux vous faire voyager dans le monde
entier sans vous faire bouger de votre
chaise avec des odeurs des saveurs en
jouant sur vos souvenirs de voyage je
peux vous emmener en Asie en Inde en
Afrique ou dans le sud de la France que
j'aime tant et vous vous y croirez
mais aussi
ça c'est le terrain jeu préféré des gens
qui pratiquent le trompe l'oeil
c'est grâce aux arômes qui peuvent être
naturels ou chimiques compte que l'on
peut faire passer du citron pour un
jaune d'œuf ou du soja pour de la viande
de bœuf
mais le pouvoir des épices et des arômes
est encore plus incroyable
comme par exemple là j'aimerais vraiment
vous faire cet exemple alors je sais ça
fait un petit peu de pub mais c'est un
très bel exemple la société s'appelle
air up je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler
c'est une société qui a fait un
excellent constat scientifique que 80%
du goût que l'on perçoit provient
provient en réalité du parfum
transporter et décodée par le nez quand
on a un rhume on sent rien on sale plus
on épices plus on met du tabasco pour
ceux qui ont le covid je suis sûr que
vous comprendrez donc ils ont conçus eux
une gourde à laquelle on va fixer un
petit anneau parfumé juste là où on met
vraiment le nez lorsqu'on lorsqu'on boit
et donc on va avoir l'impression de
boire de l'eau parfumée à la pêche à la
framboise est-ce que vous voulez alors
qu'en fait c'est de l'eau tout
simplement alors moi j'adore je trouve
que c'est exceptionnel pour l'obésité ça
peut changer énormément de choses mais
surtout moi ça m'a fait réfléchir je me
suis dit attention Justine quand tu es
au restaurant quand tu cuisines essayes
d'aller encore plus loin et lorsque le
plat arrive à vos yeux il faut aussi que
ça arrive à votre nez et ça c'est très
intéressant moi ça me plaît j'ai même
travaillé avec un barman qui juste avant
l'envoi du cocktail faisait un petit
spray sur le verre et ça prend tout de
suite une autre dimension c'est assez
exceptionnel on joue encore une fois
avec notre cerveau et nos sens
bon je vous parle pas de du côté obscur
de la Force là franchement je vous
conseille pas car dans le domaine c'est
un peu trop évident en gros on peut nous
faire manger du carton avec un joli goût
de chocolat voilà
si les trois grandes familles que
j'avais vraiment envie d'aborder avec
vous qui regroupe des techniques et des
outils pour tromper les cerveaux en
cuisine c'est un tour assez rapide je
vous l'avoue
et clairement non exhaustive mais
l'intérêt était de simplifier au maximum
pour que vous vous rappeliez comment on
peut tromper vos cerveaux avec la
couleur la texture la forme le sel et le
sucre les épices et les arômes avec
cette attirail un industriel peut donner
le goût qu'il veut la texture qu'il veut
avec de l'eau et de l'air quelquefois
ils aiment bien mettre de la farine pour
nous vendre un peu plus cher mais
franchement c'est la même chose donc
lisez bien les étiquettes et pas celle
de devant ça sert à rien c'est celle de
derrière qui est importante si vous ne
comprenez pas vous allez vite apprendre
mais c'est aussi une technique que l'on
peut faire pour faire manger des
brocolis à vos enfants ou à des gens qui
n'aiment pas les légumes en transformant
par exemple ce brocoli en purée et en
l'ajoutant dans notre brownie pour ne
pas mettre d’œuf c'est un petit
remplacement ça fait manger des légumes
et ça enlève les œufs ça c'est une belle
technique de trompe l'oeil et ça ça
permet beaucoup de choses j'ai plein
d'astuces mais tout à l'heure
c'est magique et c'est aussi ce que l'on
aime des chefs c'est que ça
ça crée finalement la surprise
ça crée aussi l'imagination ça c'est
aussi de l'émotion il va se passer
quelque chose quand vous allez au
restaurant et qu'un bon chef vous sert
une assiette qui vous trompe qui vous
crée une illusion et ben ça va vous
marquer vous allez avoir un souvenir et
ça c'est quand même exceptionnel dans
notre milieu pour ça et rien que pour ça
c'est aussi pour ça que je fais ce
métier parce que vraiment c'est quand
même incroyable de pouvoir tromper vos
cerveaux de façon bienveillante et bien
au contraire pour vous régaler donc
rappelez-vous toujours que quelqu'un a
cuisiné pour vous et que vous lui donnez
votre confiance pour cela donc ne donnez
pas votre confiance à n'importe qui
merci
[Applaudissements]